let's bring in Chris Mannix from Sports
Illustrated and covers the NBA and also
boxing which will touch on the heavy
weight the new heavyweight champ of the
world good morning Chris stop it and Dan
oh we're just getting ready the big
three-on-three league with the dance
coming up a little bit later on today I
hear uh Ricky Rubio is still available
on the market I don't know if he'd make
the starting lineup but uh you know
maybe there's a spot for Ricky Rubio and
one of the teams I mean I think we're
probably a year away from Ricky
showcasing that that three-point shot
he's been marinating the last decade
what happened to your boyfriend Ricky
Rubio
I just I bring it up look at the disc
banish'd report where it said it's the
it's your show damn that has created
this monster by the way that every time
there's like a written Rubio story I get
like 25 weeks like tagged with with you
know with Ricky Rubio stuff but
apparently the Jazz not interested
bringing back Ricky Rubio we just had a
discussion I guess you could call it
that is Andre Iguodala on his way to the
Hall of Fame I you know I saw some of
that yesterday it's like the Robert
Horry debate right like you know the
great great role player on the
championship teams in Badal is a little
bit different because we forget early in
his career
how how really good he was on both ends
in Philadelphia but I don't know he's
kind of olive very good and if you want
to create like a subsection for players
like him and Orey who are indispensable
on championship teams that's fine but I
can't put him in all of that okay what's
the difference between Ginobili and
Iguodala oh I think you nobly for her
yeah almost was how long did he play two
decades I mean he was I mean first of
all the number of Championships that he
was a driving force on and I used that
phrase because offensively
what was it for for Ginobili it wasn't
part of the first one with Duncan but
the last ones the shots he made like you
know iguodala's made some
bigshots his life but he's known in NBA
circles primarily for the defensive
stops that he makes and how he's so
versatile on that end of the floor so I
think just dis offensively Ginobili was
just more impactful than Iguodala ever
was yeah Iguodala was a better player I
think that Ginobili was more important
to his championship teams if if I you
think he was a better player than
Ginobili yeah yeah he had he was he was
better and he had a higher level that he
played at then Ginobli did I mean
Ginobili was very good and I think he's
a Hall of Famer I think that when
Iguodala was on his own as a number one
guy on his team you know Ginobili was
never the number one guy never not even
close to him the number one guy I'd have
to go back and look but we're I mean
were were those Philly teams any good
that Iguodala was nobody was still the
guy Ginobili if you're the third or
fourth option what a luxury yeah but
like it isn't the argument that you
nobly could have been what a quit dollar
was but he was an opportunity but he
yeah but he wasn't
I'm just saying Iguodala was the go-to
guy for a while and he's a you know a
great defender if you look at over 1,500
steals and over 500 blocked shots of
active players there's only four guys
and that's including Dwyane Wade who
just retired LeBron is on that list and
Iguodala so you know he he's he played
at a pretty high level I just think he
sort of had a coming-out party an
overnight sensation by what he does in
the postseason during the NBA Finals
other than that nobody talks about him
yeah you're right I mean he's his
defense is unparalleled that that in the
playoffs just because he steps in and
and just stops there becomes a stopper
on everybody you can just work him on
guys at three different positions yeah I
just I don't know I mean I think if you
if man who had his own team he's
probably a 25 point per game score and
we're talking about him and an entirely
different way I just think he his
greatest strength was his willingness to
accept whatever role he had and to
thrive in it and and that's something I
think that separates him from everybody
else anywho Donnell is doing that right
now
he is not do you think it would doll it
like when they go down
came and I forget what year was he first
came to to Golden State
he wasn't the player that that he was at
least not offensively that he was in
Philadelphia it was at a demo stage of
his career No yeah hi green yeah I look
I think she nobly is a hall-of-famer I
don't think Iguodala is I think he's
there because he's winning championships
that he's going to get a little bit more
it's almost like Edelman you know
Edelman is gonna be viewed as a Hall of
Famer borderline Hall of Fame because
he's won championships and you can't
tell the history of the NFL without
Julian Edelman and two of the greatest
catches in NFL history so I I sort of
look at maybe there's parallels there
biggest question going into Game three
for you is what he'll help with klay
Thompson I mean that's that's easy I
mean he's he's questionable with the
hamstring injury right now and you know
when I hear that Dan I think at best
he's gonna go out there and play but
guys don't just it's not like you know
you're playing through a crack the bone
in your hand or some kind of elbow
problem or shoulder problem but you can
you know sort of you know will the pain
away you can't move when you're out
there and I came at smartest Toronto and
we saw kind of the the intelligence of
Nick nurse in in Game two when he went
to that box in one which I had never
seen tronic do ever and it any points
during the season or the playoffs but
when he went to that box in one he
really slowed that word offense down and
now we've got two days to prepare for
what's probably going to be a hobbled
klay Thompson and defensively they're
gonna go at him like you know whoever
clay is guarding they're gonna go at him
and try to turn him into a liability on
that and before and for Steve Kerr to
compensate so whatever you know clay is
the wild card in all this if he's not
you know 80 85 percent able to move with
some fluidity it's gonna be problematic
yeah I think that Toronto lost the
finals and I know we still have games to
play but I think they look back on Game
two and they allowed that one to get
away from him and there was no excuse
for that
you got a wounded Golden State team on
the road and you couldn't you couldn't
close them out I think that's going to
come back and haunt them yeah I agree
you know in you know I look I look at
the Kyle Lowry game it was reminiscent
of a forget what game it was against the
law
when lowry filed out early just making
some some kind of dumb fouls and dumb
plays and that but you know that this
Raptors team has has shown some
resilience here I mean it no Golden
State's not you know Milwaukee but you
know down to zip against the Bucks and
in the Raptors rallied I mean I know
they just lost home court but I wrote
this after the game on Sunday like your
Toronto you did kind of kick that game
away you missed a lot of shots you're
probably not going to miss in in Game
three there's a lot of pressure on you
now because you're going back to Oakland
this situation but you're you're still
facing a wounded beast out there you
know there's not going to be a durant on
the floor in Game three there may not be
clay cops on the floor in Game three
you've got to go into that game thinking
you're a favorite don't you that that if
it's just Steph and draymond you can
scheme for that and you can you can try
to expose some of the other non shooters
that Golden State's throwing out there
the port not to mention I don't know
what Kevin Looney situation you're gonna
be at this point that's another big that
that Golden State will be without and
there could be relying on Bogut who has
given them decent minutes and cousins
who was gassed out there at the end I
mean I'd still think Toronto is in a
pretty good situation here I would run
that box in one if there's no clay and
no Kevin Durant I'm coming out and
playing a box in one on Steph Curry yeah
I would do I mean it was really
effective it was I I thought it was
great too it just brought back high
school bad high school memories and I
thought no wonder step called a janky
defense nobody wants to face a box in
one no and look this this again it's you
know this is why they hired Nick nurse
he's kind of got that mad scientist mind
that that allows him to adjust and use
different lineups I use different
defenses like that I mean I I'm a huge
Dwane Casey fan I think he's he's an
excellent coach but I don't think the
way in case he would have done that I
mean yeah I don't think he would have
adjusted in the same way that Nick nurse
did this is where you know coaching in a
situation like that has real value we're
talking to Chris Mannix from Sports
Illustrated senior NBA writer also
boxing writer and he was there ringside
for the big heavyweight bout between
aunt Anthony Joshua and Andy Ruiz jr.
the third this wasn't supposed to happen
when did you know something was up there
Chris that we could see one of the
bigger surprises in the heavyweight
I mean third round which was the round
of the year hands down one of the best
rounds I've ever seen in person and it's
where I as a broadcaster and you know
how this feels I'm sure Dan sometimes I
put my foot squarely into my mouth
because indeed Joshua knocked down any
Ruiz with a huge left hand left hand the
guys don't recover from so in that
moment I think I said something on lines
of Anthony Joshua is a composed
ferocious finisher everybody watched
this and then answered John right after
that so it was not my not my finest
moment as hey God caster
nobody that's the big thing like you
know people that can like that that say
any Ruiz just some big fat guy who who
should have been in this fight I mean
that's just dumb like that this was a
heralded prospect that Bob Arabs top
ranked groomed from the early stages he
had some conditioning issues clearly he
was as committed as he needed to be but
there's a talented guy with one loss on
his resume and that came in a world
championship fight he lost by like one
round so he came in with a pedigree what
I didn't think and nobody believed was
that after taking a shot like that he'd
be able to come up and answer in the way
they did that's where the big surprise
was and that was where the entire fight
changed this fight officially Dan will
go down as having ended in the seventh
round it was over in the third round
Anthony Joshua was done after getting
knocked down to beat up so much in that
third round but Ruiz and what he what he
looks like and who he represents Mexican
Americans and being the heavyweight
champ of the world I thought this was a
great thing for heavyweight boxing I saw
a lot of you know commentary to the
contrary that you know we were looking
for that showdown with Joshua and Wilder
fury thrown in there I said you got
somebody he's like John Daly when John
Daly came out of nowhere to win the PGA
Championship
you went who is this and this is
something completely different than
we've seen in the sport oh I completely
agree and that was my first reaction
right afterwards now I might have a
different opinion if the wilder fight
was scheduled
for the fall but it wasn't Wilder had
decided he was going to take a rematch
with Luis Ortiz in September and he
announced the fight with Tyson Fury for
early 2020s so we weren't getting Joshua
vs. Wilder anyway and there's a part of
me that is still disappointed that were
you know because of the politics and the
greed that's involved with boxing
promoters that were not going to get
Joshua Wilder at its apex what it could
have been the biggest fight in in this
Leeson heavyweight division this century
all that being said you now have a new
player in the heavyweight division you
now have a rematch it's going to take
place in the fall that everybody's going
to watch I bet Dan that none of your
listeners and everybody that in your
studio knows who Anthony Joshua was
scheduled to face next it was a guy
named Cooper at pulav probably in the UK
that nobody was gonna watch watch fight
now I'm guessing that when this fights
announced probably November December at
Wembley Stadium or someplace in the UK
I bet everybody's gonna watch yeah Chris
speak on Panther deaths were huge cougar
poo rat fans I'd always have been he's
joining us next he's coming up next hour
here on the book for months yeah we've
had him we had him Fritzie book to him
in April but he called cougar pulav I
think so yeah I think we need to come up
with a new heavyweight belt the WTF as
we give that to Andy Ruiz you know we
got the IBF WBC WBA in the WTF well yo
Dan you'll probably watch though like to
see it's like he can do it in front of
60,000 crazy Pro Joshua fans at Wembley
Stadium is and you'll probably wonder
like if Anthony Joshua loses this next
slide that's when his career might be
over like that was one it might be
unrecoverable at that point just one
thing about Joshua he's six six and
fights like a guy six inches shorter if
a manual Stewart was still alive he'd
need to be paired with someone like that
to be using the jab more than anything
else thank you Chris you got it that's
Chris Mannix Sports Illustrated senior
NBA and boxing writer covering boxing
for ozone for more Dan Patrick show tune
in the audience channel 239 on Direct
TV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]